[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils sont venus ils sont tous là dès
qu'ils ont entendu ce CR et le B mourir
la
[Musique]
maman ils sont venus ils sont tous là
même ceux du sud de l'Italie il y a même
Giorgio le fils maudit avec des Raon
plein les
bras tous les enfants jouent en silence
autour du lit sur le carreau mais leurs
jeux n'ont pas d'importance c'est un peu
leur dernier cadeau
à la
m on la réchauffe de baiser on lui
remonte ses oreillers elle va mourir la
maman
Sainte Marie pleine de grâce dont la
statue est sur la place bien sûr vous lu
tendez les bras en lui chantant avveé
Maria
avé
Maria il y a tant
d'amour le
souvenir autour de toi toi la
maman attend
larme et le
sourire à travers toi toi la
[Musique]
maman et tous les hommes ont eu si chaud
sur les chemins de grand soleil elle va
mourir
la
MAM qu'il boive frais le vin le Bau le
pon vin de la bonne trille tandis que
Santa se pmelle sur les bons fous
échapeaux c'est drôle on ne se sent pas
triste près du grand lit de l'affection
il y a même un oncle guitariste qui joue
en faisant attention
à la
MAM et les femmes se souvenant des
chansons tristes rveillé
mourir la
[Musique]
maman tout doucement les yeux fermés
chantent comme on berce un enfant après
une bonne journée pour qu'il sourit en
[Musique]
s'endormant
Maria il y a tant
d'amour de souvenir
autour de toi toi la
main il y a tant de
l'â et le
sourire à travers toi
toi la
MAM que
jamais que
jamais
jamais tu ne nous
quitteras
foreign